à 42 jours d'or renonce à disputer la
coupe des mains monsieur bonsoir
l'événement qui ce soir domine
l'actualité c'est l'entretien télévisé
auquel le chef de l'état a accepté de se
prêter en direct dans le cadre de notre
journal
c'est la troisième fois depuis le début
de l'année que le président mitterrand
abordera ainsi à la télévision les
grands problèmes de l'heure et les
principaux aspects de l'action de son
gouvernement
la dernière fois le 23 mars le chef de
l'état avait dans une allocution
télévisée adressé aux français un appel
solennel à l'effort national
cette fois il s'agit d'un entretien
puisque le chef de notre service
politique albert du roy
installé dans le bureau présidentiel du
palais de l'elysée va poser à monsieur
mitterrand pendant quelque 25 minutes et
avant que nous ne nous retrouvions pour
traiter du reste de la qualité albert du
roy va donc aborder avec le chef de
l'état les grands thèmes du moment
monsieur le président bonsoir albers et
d'avs du président remercie d'avoir
accepté l'invitation d'antenne 2 on
attend de votre part beaucoup de
réponses donc de ma part beaucoup de
questions la première concerne l'ordre
public
vendredi dernier les policiers créer le
désordre à paris hier soir
des sanctions sont tombées est ce que
vous considérez que l'incident est clos
alors que certains prennent ces
manifestations comme un symbole celui de
la dégradation de l'autorité de l'état
puisque vous commencé notre dialogue par
cette affaire je vous dirai tout de
suite que pour moi il est une loi qui
passe avant les autres la république
doit être honorée et servi par tous les
citoyens et plus encore parce qu'ils ont
pour mission et pour métiers de la
défense
si certains policiers une minorité
agissante ont manqué à leur devoir le
devoir des responsables de la république
c'est de frapper et de faire respecter
l'autorité de l'état
dell annonce des événements séditieux de
vendredi dernier
j'ai demandé au premier ministre de
prendre les sanctions nécessaires
il a agi comme il fallait et je suis sûr
que les français approuveront ce qui ne
veut pas dire que les problèmes posés
par l'ensemble de la police problèmes
professionnels problèmes de sécurité
doivent échapper à notre examen mais il
existe assez de responsables de gens
raisonnables dans la hiérarchie de
l'état et dans les organisations
syndicales pour que je sois bien sûr que
tout cela se traitera comme il convient
c'est à dire dans le dialogue la
concertation et l'ordre public
vous y verrez que l'ensemble de la
police et loyal certainement les
sanctions ont été prises de la base au
sommet et les ont épargné pourtant la
structure gouvernementale
le responsable les responsables de
l'intérieur de l'ue des forces de
l'ordre n'ont pas été sanctionnés vous
voulez dire le niveau politique
oui la responsabilité politique et il
est vrai qu'elle est très lié à la
responsabilité administrative je me
contenterai de vous répondre ceci c'est
à moi de décider ce qu'il convient de
décider et non pas à ceux qui veulent se
substituer aux pouvoirs en criant dans
la rue
cette réponse implique que mes
responsabilités je les assume moi même
et je me considère comme le premier
responsable des affaires publiques
il ya un peu de temps jusqu'en 1979
dernière grande manifestation populaire
et policière à paris quand les policiers
manifestaient il prenait le ministère de
l'intérieur pour cible cette fois ci
c'était en priorité le ministère de la
justice une partie probablement non
négligeable de l'opinion reproche un
certain laxisme à la justice même si les
statistiques leur donne tort comment
faire face à ce besoin de sécurité qui
se traduit laxisme c'est un mot qui sert
n'importe quoi
j'ai la plus grande le plus grand
respect pour le caractère et la
compétence du garde des sceaux et j'ai
confiance en lui
en vérité on mélange tout par passion
politique et beaucoup de gens mal
informés mais sensible et juste ont
tendance à penser que ceux qui accusent
le garde des sceaux en réseau voyez vous
nous sommes dans une situation en france
ce qui pour la première fois depuis 1789
depuis la première révolution française
veut qu'il n'y ait ni peine de mort ni
tribunaux d'exception
s'en plaindra ton on pourrait s'en
plaindre si la thymine hérité de grande
envergure si je puis dire
le crime de sang avaient progressé
depuis que ces décisions ont été prises
ce n'est pas le cas il est vrai que la
petite et moyenne délinquance s'est
développé de façon dramatique surtout
dans nos grandes villes
il est vrai qu'ils se posent des
problèmes de prévention et de sanction
nos prisons sont pleines nous avons à
nous préoccuper et ne garde des sceaux
lé fait c'est un homme d'état du devenir
d'une jeunesse souvent désaxé par la
mauvaise organisation de notre société
mais tout cela étant dit et le refus de
la violence étant exprimée par ma bouffe
et la sanction de la violence et tente
appliqué pour l'essentiel par la justice
c'est une mise en cause qui me paraît
insupportable
là les manifestations policières ont
couronné toute une série de
manifestations depuis quelques semaines
et tout dire en médecins commerçants
agriculteurs etc
derrière ces manifestations
corporatistes et c'est donc disparates
est ce que vous voyez une tentative de
déstabilisation de l'état et du beaucoup
manifestation en effet dans ce mois de
mai
c'est éternel joli mois de mai qui
d'année en année
exposé le pouvoir tous les pouvoirs qui
se succèdent à connaître l'agitation
dans la rue comme si la naissance du
printemps invités à sortir de chez soi
il ya dire très beau très fort ce que
l'on pense de la marche des affaires
publiques
très bien beaucoup de ces revendications
sont sérieuses c'est pourquoi il faut
pas mélanger l'expression de la
revendication même lorsqu'elle est
inopportune ou excessive avec la
conspiration politique que certains
amateurs de désordre qui se réclament
toujours au demeurant de l'autorité de
l'état que certains amateurs de désordre
en profite c'est évident mais ce n'est
pas l'essentiel
voyez vous je veux porter la plus grande
attention est le plus grand scrupule aux
revendications socioprofessionnelles il
ya beaucoup de gens malheureux et plus
encore il ya beaucoup de gens inquiets
et mon rôle est celui du gouvernement
c'est d'expliquer peut-être même
d'expliquer davantage de justifier les
mesures d'approfondir le dialogue si
cela est négligée et bien cela sera
corrigé mais une fois dit le scrupule
une fois dit l'attention que je porte à
ses revendications
à mon tour d'exprimer deux exigences la
première c'est que cette revendication
s'exprime pacifiquement et non pas dans
la violence
la deuxième c'est que cet intérêt
particulier serait-il légitime ne doit
pas se substituer à l'intérêt général
c'est pas moi qui dit que la somme des
intérêts particuliers ne faisait pas
l'intérêt général bon et évitons les
choses trop souvent entendue mais ça
mérite d'être clair donc la violence non
j'observe d'ailleurs que certaines
catégories socioprofessionnelles ont
beaucoup bougé cet ancien que d'autres
montrer au fonds beaucoup de patience si
l'on fait ce compte toujours un peu
détestable des
pour de grève d'une année sur l'autre
l'année 1982 and 1983
on montrait une classe ouvrière sachant
très souvent le plus souvent dominé ses
propres indications de telle sorte que
je suis convaincu qu'il est de large
fraction de l'opinion française qui se
rend compte à la fois conduisant à vue
lui qu'on est en démocratie on va dire
ce qu'on pense
on le dit mais en même temps on tient à
préserver l'unité nationale
on respecte l'état on veut que la
république fonctionnent
pour le bien du plus grand nombre et
bien moi je pense comme ça et je suis
disposé à tous les dialogues ou des
positions que j'ai dit en premier les
causes du malaise de l'inquiétude de la
crise de confiance que traduisent un
certain nombre d' enquêtes d'opinion il
y en a une qui vous concerne directement
et qui revient souvent c'est
l'impression que vous avez eu que vous
avez à choisir entre deux politiques de
nomique lune qui est douloureuse que
celle de la rigueur que vous avez choisi
et une autre qui serait moins
douloureuse et que vous ne tiendriez en
réserve avec d'autres hommes pour la
mener yat-il existe-t-il d'une politique
de rechange celle qui est pratiquée en
ce moment je voudrais pouvoir vous
répondre avec précision
vous me permettrez donc de d'occuper
quelques minutes de cette brève émission
pour tenter de me faire comprendre le
mieux possible
c'est vrai que la crise du monde
occidental a atteint des limites qu'on
ne connaissait pas depuis la grande
crise de 1929 et de 1930 qui comme vous
le savez a eu tant de répercussions non
seulement sur la situation sociale du
monde auquel nous appartenons
mais sur la paix du monde tout entier
voilà une situation dont il faut tenir
compte
la crise mondiale
à quoi s'ajoutent les retards accumulés
pendant dix ans par l'économie française
tout cela crée une situation que j'ai
mal géré et administré à dominer j'ai
donc appelé au redressement national
en tentant de faire comprendre pas
toujours avec succès que rétablir ou
établir plus de justice sociale entre
les groupes qui composent la nation
française
c'était la première chose à faire
lorsqu'on ne peut pas demander des
sacrifices à des gens qui ont le
sentiment que c'est toujours à eux qu'on
lui demande
la notion de privilège croyez-moi
interdit bien des espérances
alors se pose la question qui vient tout
de suite à votre esprit mais moi je vais
en poser trois questions
en réponse la première est celle ci il
me semble que les français s'interrogent
on le voit bien et que la première
question qui est la leur et celle ci
après tout est-ce que c'était ford ne
pourrait pas être évité est-il bien
nécessaire
et à ce moment là apparaît la politique
de rechange si quelqu'un me le dire ben
oui on a une autre
moi je réponds aucune politique
quelques moyens qu'elle préconise ne
dispensera des français de l'effort
nécessaire et cet effort
il doit porter sur quoi peut-il être
évité par exemple de contenir le budget
de l'état est ce qu'il est vraiment
évitables de rétablir l'équilibré des
budgets sociaux des régimes sociaux
est-ce qu'on peut hésiter d'équilibrer
le commerce extérieur dont dépend d'une
certaine façon le sort de notre monnaie
us ils ne voient plus loin
l'indépendance nationale peut-on éviter
la concurrence internationale
peut-on se contenter de consommer sans
épargner alors qu'en réalité il faut
l'équilibré du budget d'état l'équilibré
des régimes sociaux l' équilibre du
commerce extérieur alors qu'il faut et
parier alors qu'il faut accepter la
concurrence des autres
si cette concurrence déloyale alors
qu'il faut préparer l'avenir en amassant
pour le prévenant ou pour le présent
tout en préservant l'emploi ce qui n'est
pas si facile
vous l'imaginez bien et en établissant
la justice sociale dont je parlais tout
à l'heure je suis pas vous l'aurez ce
que vous croyez que cela est possible
sans que j'en appelle comme je le fais
depuis quelques mois ou courage à
l'intelligence à la résolution des
français il faut une résolution sans
faille
croyez moi est ce que ce n'est pas très
ambitieux de vouloir tout faire à la
fois chez les cd pack et je ne vaille
c'est que cela est également nécessaire
je dois être moi même
le premier responsable et lorsque
j'examine l'ensemble des problèmes qui
se posent à moi ce dont j'ai hérité ce
qui se développe aujourd'hui jeudi que
la politique du gouvernement est
nécessaire parce que l'effort l'est
lui-même et que cet effort ne peut pas
être évité par quelque autre politique
que ce soit alors la deuxième question
je ne voudrais pas être trop longs car
nous avons autre chose à dire la
deuxième question c'est celle ci mais
alors est-ce que c'était fort et juste
est-ce qu'il est équitablement réparti
bon on comprend on admet on veut bien
c'est nécessaire il faut rétablir les
affaires de la france
mais alors soyez juste et je retiens je
reprends mon raisonnement du tout à
l'heure sur le sentiment de justice et
d'égalité est très développé dans la
nation française est ce que c'est juste
nous nous efforçons je peux même dire
que le gouvernement depuis deux ans et
celui qui a le plus réalisé pour la
justice sociale entre les français même
s'il est imparfait
depuis des générations je ne vais pas
énumérer ce serait là sans et pourtant
j'en ai bien envie mais je ne veux pas
étaler ce qui a été répété souvent même
si cela n'est pas toujours entrer dans
les esprits vous savez ce n'est pas si
facile de rétablir une justice sociale
si longtemps négligé tout ce qui a été
fait pour que les français puissent
disposer même parle la législation
fiscale l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes
le fait de d'exempter les plus faibles
savez-vous qu'à l'heure actuelle le au
moment où arrivent les feuilles d'impôts
7 millions de foyers fiscaux enfin on va
dire de ménage sont exemptés de du 1 %
sur le revenu imposable savez-vous que
14 millions de français sont exemptés de
l'emprunt ce forum france forcé mais
remboursable ce que les bénéficiaires
rejet il ajouté j'ajoute que les efforts
qui ont été faits pour les personnes
âgées pour les familles pour les
handicapés qui ont été faits au cours de
tous ses deux premières années afin que
les démunis les bas salaires puissent
vivre vivre mieux tout simplement sans
vivre bien tout cela c'est la justice
sociale et je voudrais que généraliser
ce raisonnement je veux qu aucune mesure
de rigueur ne soit prise n'est appliquée
sans qu'elle soit accompagnée de mesures
sociale et de mesures de justice
l'effort sera accomplie s'il est
accompli par tous eh bien disons en
raison des moyens dont chacun dispose
c'est comme cela que nous irons plus
loin si la troisième question
celle-ci bon est-ce que l'effort
pourrait être évitée jeudi n'ont aucune
politique de rechange ne dispenserait
les français de cet effort de est-ce que
cet effort est juste bien je m'explique
il n'est pas toujours aussi juste que je
voudrais assurément mais j'y crois de
toutes mes forces
j'y consacre mon temps et le
gouvernement avec moi la troisième
question et ceci est ce que ça sert à
quelque chose
vraiment ce serait désespérant de penser
que depuis déjà quelques temps beaucoup
de foyers français souffrent renonce se
sentent gênés aux entournures
beaucoup de gens de petits moyens et si
en même temps ils ont le sentiment que
tout ce qu'on fait ça sert à rien alors
il abandonne il n'y croit plus ils
firent mm par an ne puis croire
ressources de leur propre pays
naturellement quand on a un enfant
chômage
wahou menace d'être chômeur ou quittent
encore tout jeune qui a tiendra à 17 ans
18 ans et qui deviendra un chômeur
puisque ce sont les jeunes de moins de
25 ans qui fournissent la moitié des
chômeurs actuellement on peut désespérer
moi je dis cet effort est nécessaire et
il doit être juste pour qu'il serve à
quelque chose
alors ce quelque chose c'est d'abord la
bataille contre l'inflation et contre le
chômage on a ressassé toutes ces choses
parce qu'il faut bien le répéter puisque
l'inflation et le chômage occupe
absolument la scène internationale
depuis 1973 c'est un couple infernal et
vous observerez que nous avons voulu
nous on a estimé que c'était trop
ambitieux s'attaquer sur les deux fronts
à la fois bon certains ont mieux réussi
sur le plan de l'inflation bien que nous
ayons eu depuis 1973 les premiers à
redresser la situation par rapport à
l'inflation
nous avons trouvé 14% nous en sommes à
neuf et demi
ou plutôt nous allons vers 8% à la fin
de l'année 1983 et l'objectif c'est 5 %
en 1984 mais en même temps nous n'avons
pas voulu lâcher la rampe
pour l'emploi nous n'avons pas voulu que
le chômage s'empare comme il l'a fait
aux états unis d'amérique en grande
bretagne trois millions cinq cent mille
chômeurs et comme cela commence être le
cas en allemagne nous n'aurons pas voulu
que le chômage dévore notre société
moralement psychologiquement
matériellement ans je reconnais que
c'est une tentative très difficile il
est très difficile d'apprécier
exactement la mesure le point où la
lutte contre l'inflation nécessaire si
on ne réussit pas dans cette bataille et
bien notre monnaie sera très compromise
nos équilibres ne seront pas réalisés et
la france ne sera pas en situation de
supporter la compétition internationale
elle perdra une large part de son
indépendance
c'est une passe à dix ans la peine c'est
pourquoi je dis il faut que ça serve à
quelque chose
l'entreprise est difficile nous sommes
quand même ceux qui ont le mieux réussi
du monde industriel sur le plan de le
tromper
comment va-t-on diom pour contenir le
chômage et nous allons vers un rythme
d'inflation supportable les deux choses
à la fois je veux que l'on comprenne que
c'est très difficile
que faut-il abandonner rien
naturellement abandonner la lutte contre
l'inflation alors c'est le désastre
économique
abandonner la lutte contre le chômage
alors c'est le désastre humain je veux
que l'on comprenne cela mais il ya
d'autres points sur lesquels ça sert à
quelque chose
il y a que je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
les équilibres il y a le commerce
extérieur et cela commence croyez-moi on
le verra dans les chiffres prochain cela
commence à se sentir notre aux
exportations s'améliore nos importations
diminuent très bien voilà quelque chose
non pas d'acquis mais qui commence à se
dessiner puis l'épargnant on épargne et
oui on épargne et de livrer populaire
que livre l épargne populaire 2 millions
de français des sommes importantes
il y à un bond en avant des émissions
d'obligations il compte d'épargné
logement
il y a un peu partout véritablement a
besoin d'épargné puis il ya la formation
des jeunes savez vous qu'on a au cours
de ces derniers temps 1981-82 organiser
la formation professionnelle de près
d'un million de jeunes gens c'est vous
que le premier miss a pris les
engagements
et le financement de près de huit cent
mille jeunes gens pour 1984 je vais dire
ça risquerait d'être trop long cela sert
à quelque chose et cela sert en même
temps au développement social à
l'harmonie sociale voilà j'en ai assez
dit pour cela je ne pense pas mais je le
dis absolument sans présomption sans
vouloir nier que d'autres esprits
peuvent penser autrement et c'est
légitime dans une démocratie de penser
autrement
mais je dis clairement il n'y a pas de
politique de rechange d'autres qui sont
des proches qui ont ou qui ont eu votre
confiance à la tête du parti socialiste
ou dans des fonctions importantes disent
le contraire semble dire qu'il y à une
autre politique
bon je sais que drôle d'un parti
politique c'est de débattre et que c'est
normal et que ça fait la richesse du
parti socialiste mais comment espérer
que la majorité des français qui vous
ont élu ne soit pas ébranlée si cela sud
kivu sont proches disent le contraire de
ce que vous dites monsieur du roi il
faut pas se tromper d'époque ce type de
problème seul est connue pendant
longtemps souvent lorsque j'étais le
premier responsable de ce grand parti
politique ce n'est plus le cas je suis
aujourd'hui présidente et tous les
français et je ne me mêle pas des
problèmes internes aux partis politiques
y compris du parti politique vous été
leurré les si le doute
j'entends bien j'ai étudié de près comme
je le fais pour tous les propositions
qui ont été faites
j'ai constaté qu'il y avait variation
contradictions sur les moyens ce n'est
pas constatée sur les objectifs je
souhaite je le dis très simplement je le
souhaite que là comme ailleurs
aucun responsable politique ne prenne le
risque même pour des raisons
parfaitement compréhensible de
compromettre les langues nationales et
j'ai assez confiance dans le sens
civique de ce dont je parle pour savoir
que s'il est tout à fait normal que par
rapport à leur propre parti ils
débattent tout c'est un honneur que de
pouvoir d
dans un parti vraiment démocratique il
faut que l'on sache bien que l'état
allait responsabilité générale qui passe
avant tout les autres j'en suis le
garant en tout cas et je devais vous le
dire les communistes qui sont aussi des
partenaires de la majorité
présidentielle ne se contente pas de
critiquer la politique économique et
sociale qui est actuellement menée
il critique aussi l'un des aspects
essentiels de la politique étrangère qui
est la politique de défense
jusqu'où peuvent-ils aller dans leurs
critiques que sans que vous en tiriez
des conséquences politiques
je crois qu'il faut toujours distinguer
la manière de faire d'un parti politique
de ce qui est le gouvernement de la
république gouvernement la france
je n'ai pas constaté au sein des
gouvernements de la france de
différentes qui en est fait et
poseraient la question que vous voulez
de me poser quant aux partis politiques
gras je me demande vraiment quel
président de la république a de ce point
de vue est épargné au cours des
décennies précédentes
c'est dans la norme d'un débat qui est
celui de notre république
mais vannes au fond si vous voulez bien
car je ne veux pas éluder votre question
c'est parler de la défense en
particulier sur l'économique je pourrai
répondre alors ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure et je ne veux pas me répéter
mais parlons de la défense il faut que
chacun comprenne bien mes raisons si
l'on veut je serai obligé d'être bref
donc de simplifier un peu trop
enfin nous allons reparler de m'asseoir
devant lui jean bart et de l'asseoir en
effet dans une grande circonstances en
simplifiant tout en restant disons dans
une explication claire et honnête
disons qu'il existe en gros un équilibre
des forces
on appelle stratégique on pourrait dire
inter continental entre les états unis
d'amérique et l'union soviétique
mais il n'existe pas d' équilibre en
europe ce qui se caractérise par la
comparaison des armements dit
tactique ou intermédiaire des forces
nucléaires qui ne traverse pas
l'atlantique et qui donc ne peuvent
avoir pour destination que le continent
noir
à cet égard le seul pays en europe à
disposer de forces nucléaires
intermédiaire c'est l'union soviétique
élan possède beaucoup 350 à 360 fusée
dit ss20 avec trois charges ou trois
ogives choisissons le mot pour voudra
qui multiplie par trois mille 50 milles
90 ch qui peuvent atteindre je lis
souvent dit je répète en un quart
d'heure la totalité des dispositifs
militaires du nord de la norvège au sud
de l'italie
est-ce que l'union soviétique doit avoir
monopole dans cet armement évidemment
terrible je dis non et je suis sûr que
tous les français disent non avec moi
l'enjeu borde la discussion et jeudi il
est nécessaire de réaliser un certain
équilibre en europe et comme décision
était prise par vers la france mais par
des occidentaux au sein de l'otan'' pour
tenter d'équilibrer par l'arrivée de
fusées américaines sur le continent
européen
la présence des fusées soviétiques je ne
dis pas à remonter sur arbon engageons
nous dans une course dont on ne sait
quelle serait finalement vainqueur
de toute façon c'est nazi même qu'ils
perdraient l'espèce humaine
la terre tous ceux qui vivent sur ce sol
jeudi
négocions et j'approuve la négociation
de genève qui a lieu actuellement
sans avancer beaucoup entre les russes
et les américains négociation dans
laquelle nous ne sommes pas et à
laquelle nous ne participerons pas bien
entendu alors
que penser de cette négociation je dis à
tous les français qui m'écoutent qu'elle
ne réussira pas sur la base des
propositions émises jusqu'à lors par les
autorités soviétiques et pas davantage
par l'option zéro proposés par monsieur
reagan c'est à dire par la liquidation
immédiate et intégrale et préalable de
l'armement soviétique donc cette
négociation n'aboutira pas elle aurait
pu aboutir
les propositions ont été mises d'accord
par les deux principaux négociateurs
mais sionistes et américains
j'écris ce qui le virus l'année dernière
au mois de mai sur une base c'est
raisonnable
cela n'a été accepté par aucun des deux
gouvernements
la négociation est à l'heure actuelle
pratiquement arrêté est en avance vers
le mois de décembre où les américains
ont dit qu'ils installeraient en
allemagne les fusées pershing qui elles
sont également guéris et menace en ce
qu'elles sont ressenties comme une
menace par l'union soviétique c'est
contre cette perspective là que les
communistes français se critiquent la
position du gouvernement il ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'ils critiquent ou
plutôt ne critique la position que j'ai
prise ou qui pensent que j'ai prise
ah oui à 9 heures car il n'avait pas
élevé d'objections ou discours que j'ai
prononcé sur ce sujet veut à bonn devant
le bundestag
mais je n'ai pas changé de politique je
dis simplement il n'est pas possible que
la france n'est pas possible que
l'europe de l'ouest restent désarmés
reste à ce point est au-dessous de
l'armement soviétique puisque d'un côté
il y à un armement de leur côté il n'y
en a pas je veux dire un armement de ce
type c'est à dire les forces nucléaires
intermédiaire donc je forme des voeux
pour que la négociation aboutisse qui
est déjà en désaccord avec cela je
souhaite que les deux principaux
partenaires renonce à certaines de leurs
exigences qui peut être hostile à cela
je souhaite que ce soit la négociation
et non pas le nez préalable d
de puissants pays la négociation qui
détermine elle même le niveau du
déploiement diffusé s'il doit y avoir
des moments diffuser ou mieux encore
mais cela me paraît dépassé un accord
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de déploiement
alors je défends les intérêts de la
france moi ceux qui vous critiquent tout
entier c'est la défense de la france et
la sécurité des français
et j'ajoute bien entendu mais je n'ai
pas de contradiction à cet égard
j'ajoute que nous avons à côté cela la
force française qui est de nature
stratégique qui n'est pas comparable à
la force soviétique il n'est pas de même
nature
le team tuellement assurent de façon
dissuasive l'essence yves la sécurité du
pays je n'ai pas l'intention de renoncer
à ces données qui me permette et qui
permette à la france te regarder
l'avenir en face pas du tout à l'heure
de la politique économique et beaucoup
de défense des gunners
la réussite de cette politique
économique que vous avez rappelé notera
que les grandes lignes dépend largement
en partie du cours du dollar ou moins
qu'on puisse dire
depuis le sommet de william burke c'est
que ça ne s'est pas arrangée alors
rapidement
à quoi sert d'aller à quoi servent ils à
zot si vite qu'il est possible et donc
résumée en termes synthétique ce qui
était le pour et le contre
le pour seule la relation entre les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement dans de
bonnes conditions
c'est une certaine amorce vers le
tiers-monde
c'est une certaine ouverture sur un
meilleur système monétaire international
et c'est la mise un peu au rancart de la
dispute sur le commerce est ouest - le
contre c'est que williams burns n'a pas
répondu à l'attenté de ses millions de
travailleurs évident les syndicats
notamment les syndicats européens qui
attendait des propositions pour
l'organisation du travail le partage du
travail la défense de l'emploi
c'est que williams burns n'a pas répondu
à la tente des pays du tiers monde qui
attendait autre chose afin de permettre
aux termes de l' échange
de reprendre de ne pas écraser notamment
sous le poids du dollar les pays
aujourd'hui endettés qui composent deux
tiers monde oui à ce bug n'a pas répondu
à l'attenté de tous les pays du monde
qui s'offre du prix du dollar qui
s'offre des taux d'intérêt on fait de
l'argent aux états unis d'amérique et
donc du déficit budgétaire américain
qu'il paye d'une certaine façon
enfin le contre oui à ce bug n'est pas
lé bien ri dans la direction de
conférence monétaire internationale que
j'ai moi même ce qui vaut rejet ou dire
ma conclusion c'est que j'ai des doutes
sur l'utilité de ces sommets annuels
du moins sous leur forme actuelle oui
j'ai des doutes
ce qui est bon la relation personnelle
entre les chefs d'état et gouvernement
17 du grand pays industriel du monde est
gravement altérée par cette étonnante
diplomatie puis tambourinage et des
enchères publiques qui a désormais
désormais pris le pas sur le reste et
qui empêche de négocier utilement
pourriez alors j'ai fait dire que je ne
crois pas cette évolution heureuse et je
ne vais pas que la politique de la
france s'y mêlent davantage à moins bien
entendu on change radicalement de
méthode
c'est un avertissement pour le prochain
semestre
je crois que cela pût être compris me
suis exprimée en langage clair les
périodes allusif mais la question
monsieur le président votre septennat
commencé il ya tout de suite plus de
deux ans il a commencé par des réformes
ambitieuses s'est continuée par la
rigueur et aujourd'hui tout le monde lit
que vous et votre gouvernement vous
contenter de gérer alors la gestion
c'est un terme très raisonnable ce n'est
pas très enthousiasmant pour le reste du
temps qui vous appartient quel est le
projet sur lequel vous voudriez
mobiliser les français c'est une
critique quand même quand même injuste
mais en même temps une remarque que sage
on ne peut pas dire aux français fait
l'effort
même s'il est juste même s'il est
nécessaire et même s'il est utile
aujourd'hui ils ne peuvent agir que
s'ils ont le sentiment vous l'avez dit
d'un projet d'un projet pour les jeunes
on ne résoudra pas la crise si les
jeunes ne sont pas formés aux
disciplines technologiques qu'ils auront
à appliquer lorsqu'ils seront adultes
or les technologies changent vite il
faut donc que les hommes soient formés
pour le travail qu'ils font et or la
soul a pu être fait avec enthousiasme
car on ouvre des horizons nouveaux
efforts essentiel le deuxième c'est
qu'il faut croire dans les capacités de
l'intelligence et du courage français
l'industrie notamment
nous avons vraiment réussi dans beaucoup
de domaines les transports lé
télécommunications le nucléaire
l'automobile qui se redresse vite
aujourd'hui fait partie des transports
en fait il fallait noter au passage
l'électronique
nous avons repris la machine-outil nous
allons nous attaquer aux boyaux cuir et
ce tir etc
puis il ya la conquête de l'espace et
puis il y à la conquête des hommes dans
le bon sens du terme c'est à dire que la
france aujourd'hui est respecté dans le
monde entier est attendue et espérée par
l'ensemble du tiers-monde
comme je peux le dire elle ne l'a jamais
été je mens tout cela n'est possible que
si la formation des jeunes que si le
développement industriel moderne comme
il convient qu'il soit est en même temps
à sortir d'une politique des hommes
c'est à dire d'une politique de la
natalité les politiques de la
démographie d'une politique des familles
il y a quelque chose dans les politiques
ne parlent jamais mais enfin ce cercle
de famille sur lesquels on reprend force
qui fonder sur les sentiments les plus
secrets les plus forts les chances
d'espérance tiennent aussi au nombre des
français sans exagérer la chose il faut
quand même que les générations se
perpétue il y aura réponse à beaucoup de
choses et bien à cet égard il y a
beaucoup à faire et je vous en
convaincre les français oui je crois que
le projet qui s'esquisse et à travers
tous mes propos car lorsque je disais
tout à l'heure au milieu de notre
conversation
cela sert à quelque chose déjà
j'abordais ce sujet je crois vraiment
que le gouvernement de la france
aujourd'hui en dépit de la rigueur qu'il
doit appliquer qui n'est pas un objectif
mais qui est un moyen n'a jamais perdu
de vue que nous devions esquissé projet
de civilisation reposant sur une
meilleure appréhension du monde
technologique industriel qui est le
nôtre d'une meilleure formation
éducation de la jeunesse un plus grand
sens de ses devoirs appuyez sur eux un
rayonnement et une gens qu'on aime qu'on
aime voir et rencontrer retrouver
pendant tout le temps de l'asie et bien
croyez moi cela ou si c'est la politique
de la france
moi je voudrais mais la simple mot que
j'ai pour passion et pour de voir les
choses s'additionnent la sécurité
l'indépendance du pays
cela aussi c'est un projet je veux dire
sa grandeur efficacité clarté autorités
je suis bien qu'on en discute beaucoup
je dis très tranquillement que pour le
service de la france rien de